Computer systems initially had limited capability,
so commercial vendors focused on a specific hospital department,
such as the laboratory or pharmacy.
As the use of these departmentally specific systems grew,
their inability to share data across vendors became problematic.
This led to the formation of the non-profit standards setting organization,
Health Level 7, and the development of
the first successful messaging standard for health data sharing.
This early standard was based on EDI X 12 technology for manufacturing in the 1980's.
You can see an example here,
and surprisingly, it's still in widespread use.
Over time, a few large vendors emerged with systems designed to meet
most of the major computing needs of a hospital and its associated clinics.
For reasons we will discuss later on,
meaningful clinical data sharing among these mega systems was problematic.
And independent access to the data they stored was very.